A less popular,
less frequently used structural diagram
is the composite structure diagram.
This one is used for showing
the internal structure of a class.
Of particular interest to
us are its interfaces.
So on the left side of
the interior class here are two
horizontal lines coming out.
The top one with the circle on the edge
of it is a Provides Interface.
That's saying that this class
provides some capabilities to
the rest of the world.
Under it is another line coming out and
this one with a semicircle that's open.
This is a Requires Interface, that is,
what does this class require
from the rest of the world?
You can then imagine having a variety
of classes that plug into each other.
That is, a provides from one class plugs
into a requires from another class.
This is one way of putting together
the pieces of a software architecture.